make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
we're with us continuing I can't talk
I'm Ron Burgundy
with us continuing our our Transformers
coverage but we need to make a more
solidified schedule but with us covering
more more transformer stuff while we're
all kind of stuck in our homes initially
I thought about just kind of jumping in
with like more than meets the eye and
robots in disguise but I realized that
like we never finished all hail Megatron
so we're gonna kind of like run through
all hail Megatron and then kind of jump
forward from there so I don't really
expect this to be like an overly popular
series but I do want to kind of get it
covered and get it finished and sort of
call it a day so in the last the really
the first video that we did two years
ago God has really been that long in the
first video that we did two years ago we
essentially had this scenario where like
the Decepticons had shown up on earth
and basically conquered it right like
and they're they're conquering of Earth
happened like that I mean like humanity
had no real chance against the power of
the other Decepticons because one
they're just so technologically advanced
and two in comparison to humanity's
weaponry they're just so weak and so for
the most part the story had largely kind
of followed the exploits of two
characters the first one was a guy named
bridge and the second one was a guy
named Andy and Andy was really just like
one of multiple people out there who had
been sort of mobilized by the military
and in effort to try to take out the
Decepticons and much like most other
members of the military he ended up
failing you know in fact a lot of other
members ended up dying but Andy was one
of the survivors right and so following
that he ended up coming across a bridge
who of course also came across a woman
named Sarah
Umbridge kind of stepped in to help save
some people's lives and so there really
isn't any real connection to these guys
outside of the fact that they all just
kind of happen to meet each other in the
midst of this veritable apocalypse right
and so for the most part Humanity is
really on its last stand that's really
all it is like there's really nothing
they can do and so what this does is it
picks up with the Decepticons and and
basically Megatron kind of addressing
all the Decepticons who were here and
basically saying we've successfully
conquered earth right like the earth is
ours nobody can stand in our way
like humanity as a whole is completely
and totally broken now this also begs
the question where are the Autobots okay
so one of the things that's kind of
hidden to hint it out here over the
course of this story is that there's a
traitor among the ranks of the Autobots
we don't know for sure and we don't know
who it is but all we know is that at the
moment because of the actions of this
traitor that Optimus Prime is
essentially out of commission like
literally on a table just kind of in
shame
and not really functioning and the
Autobots themselves were basically
overcoming and really kind of left is a
sort of ragtag group by the Decepticons
which kind of left the path open by
virtue of this trader for the
Decepticons to target and conquer earth
that's kind of what's going on at the
moment the reality of this is that there
there is some stuff going on with the
Autobots but they're just not that
interesting in comparison to what's
going on with the Decepticons right
because if you guys are anything like me
bad guys are way more interesting than
good guys right like I love Decepticons
it's a cool thing I always like the
villains more than I like the heroes now
the funny thing about bridge and really
in the aftermath what we saw in the last
video which is to say with this kind of
safe haven you know sort of being a
location for like bridge and for Sarah
and for Andy and the various other
people they managed to save or sort of
rally to their cause where they had some
measure of a safe haven the Decepticons
came like rolling in and trashed the
place and so as a result of that it kind
of destroyed this feeling of like safety
right it was kind of a chance for
humanity to catch their breath only for
this ragtag band to suddenly have it
yanked away and bridge is kind of
watching all this go down and it's just
sort of like whatever man and is
interesting because Sarah steps in and
she's just like get it together man like
what do you want to be or not these
people see you as a leader and where he
doesn't really want to be the guy who
leads anyone the result is that they see
him that way anyway and so because of
that is essentially his job to keep
things organized
either that or kind of let it all fall
to chaos and it's kind of a weird
predicament to be in you can kind of see
bridges perspective where it's like what
they're grown functioning human beings
that are capable of rational thought if
this is how they're acting in a state of
panic then all they're doing is just
being themselves right it's only in a
state of extreme duress and in
desperation that people show you who
they really are everything up until that
point it's just a facade right that's
kind of an attitude or a mindset that
can be adopted here but at the same time
it's also one of these things worse like
those who have the ability to do
something have the responsibility to do
something right so essentially it comes
down to how much do you care about other
people right that's that's really what
it is and up to this point bridge
doesn't really seem to care he's just
kind of like it does really matter to me
what they do I like they can do their
own thing they can get it together or
they can not get it together I don't
care like as long as I survive and as
long as you survive we're gonna be fine
at that moment
Sarah causes manhood and the question is
like what kind of man are you
right like are you a man who stands for
something or are you a coward who just
cares about his own skin like nut up
be a leader that's just the way that it
is you may not like it but that's the
world that's been thrust on you suck it
up and learn to deal with it Umbridge
really kind of takes this takes us to
heart and really kind of you know ends
up jumping in so what we do here is we
end up picking up with we're really with
a kernel wit wiki and then like a young
guy who's brought in and of course when
this kid comes in our we basically
enough finding out this is wit wiki son
right and so from there you end up
having this this really sort of
interesting conversation between the two
why would they kind of initially start
to talk about things like you know how's
your mother doing and and so on and so
forth and so when you're talking about
this guy spike with the relationship
between his father isn't really given
here outside of anything other than they
embrace each other and they seem to have
a good situation going on the problem
with this is that spikes role really
kind of seems to be like black on a
black officer subterfuge or something
like that where basically he sneaks into
locations engages in particular actions
and sneaks out right so if we can
largely assume that maybe he's something
akin to like an Army Ranger or like a
Navy SEAL or something like that
whatever the case is you know he kind of
does some some espionage stuff and so as
a result of this he's really kind of
been tasked or really you know
unwillingly being tasked by his father
to carry out a mission and the reason
why is because he basically shows him a
picture of Megatron and that while
Humanity is really on the ropes and
humanity really has nothing to offer
here in the way of being able to combat
these various Decepticons that they've
seen enough being broadcast by virtue of
the the Decepticons trying to instill
fear terror panic different things like
that they've seen enough to realize that
Megatron is the one that they that they
basically answer to and so with that
being the case the idea is we kind of
have a plan on what can be done to
basically take this guy out and what
they're talking about here what they
really kind of seems to be looking at is
the idea of using a nuclear warhead and
the reality is that wit wiki doesn't
want to send a son out there but at the
end of the day it's his job it's what he
specializes in and so as a result of
that wit wiki kind of has to send his
son out there and really kind of cross
his fingers and hope for the best
because I imagine from wit wiki's
perspective he's kind of hoping the
mission goes off without a hitch but he
really hopes his son survives more than
anything else the problem with this is
that you know they're kind of monitoring
these guys vital signs to know whether
or not you know they're they're
succeeding and they basically sent them
across their way they get halfway across
and they're obliterated by a Decepticon
and it's just kind of like wow or like
just like that the mission failed that
right there that moment right there I
think really highlights how outmatched
humanity is
outmatched they are that every step they
take to try to find some way to win this
win this battle or win this war with the
Decepticons there immediately nipped in
the bud right it's like it's it's
essentially like trench warfare I don't
want any of the guys have it read read
anything about World War one
but like the idea was that during World
War one those individuals who stuck
their head above the trenches the
average lifespan was like eight seconds
or something like that right like you
pick your head up
and within like eight to ten seconds
you'd be dead it was something along
those lines that's what this is they
take one step one one foot out the door
dead you know whit Ricky's father just
kind of starts starts freaking out right
because it's just kind of like dude my
son is absolutely dead the funny thing
about this is that what we end up
learning is that that's not true
spike is the only one of his men that
seems to have made it out alive right
and he's all the way on the other side
and from what we can tell intending to
go full-bore with his mission now the
other part of this is Starscream
Starscream was one of these characters
where he was always vying to replace
Megatron he was always looking to be the
the guy who is leading the leading the
Decepticons and depending on whether
you're a fan of him or not there are
those who make the argument the
Starscream would actually be a better
leader of the Decepticons that Megatron
is and then there are others who are
just like Starscream's a poor-man's
Megatron might a poor-man's Galvatron
you know I thought people look at it or
how some people look at him the reality
is I think Starscream it's better but
the thing that makes his character so
cool is he's not really about just like
overtly challenging Megatron why that
never really happened that's not how
that works
it's swindling other people to his cause
right bringing other people to his side
it's going to this guy and saying hey
man like I think Megatron how do you
think he's leading things right like I
mean things could be a little bit better
could may and the other person can like
yeah I mean things are a little rough
it's like you know it's like man this
never would have happened if I was the
one leaving the Decepticons and it's
just little things like that right like
planting seeds of doubt plotting and
scheming and things like that
that's what makes him so cool and it's
one of these things where he kind of
calls Megatron into question asking
things like what's the point of all this
and that's that's really kind of the
question that was being asked over the
course of all this right what was a
point of attacking Earth and that's what
Starscream's question is like why did we
conquer this place right what's the
purpose what does it matter right like
you know conquering earth doesn't give
us some kind of technology that will
allow us to like destroy all the
Autobots like it's not as though Earth
was home to like some insanely high
level technological stuff that could
like allow us to point a gun at like all
the Autobots and just
wipe them out all at one time humanity
hasn't liked nukes and but these are all
primitive weapons right they've got
satellites that beam television signals
how advanced could they possibly be
right like that's that's kind of
Starscream's perspective here you know
but it's not really the idea of
challenging and saying like we we've to
do something better it's designed to
kind of undermine Megatron to kind of
just kind of you know remind him hey man
just so you know I think you're full of
crap I think you're a terrible leader I
don't think you have any real plan here
and that's what Starscream kind of
points out when do you think everybody's
gonna start turning on you right because
people are gonna start asking questions
like why are we here what's the point of
this great big huge battle what's the
next step of this plan and Megatron
doesn't really have one you know he just
showed up on earth to conquer it and
that's it right it was kind of his grand
scheme it's the thing he always wanted
to do and now that he's achieved of the
question is what comes next and not
having an answer to that question that's
what ends up making things really kind
of a kind of difficult form and so from
there what we end up doing is we end up
picking up in Versailles France would be
with what's left of the United Nations
and the United Nations is essentially
analyzing everything that's going down
there kind of having these sort of cores
of discussions and so on and so forth
and then it is kind of like okay let's
get down to business let's get down to
brass tacks --is you know and and see
what's what and so what they start doing
is going over all the facts right
America is totally conquered the United
States is lost the government doesn't
really exist what's left of it is kind
of split all over the place the
president nobody really seems you
running the show outside of like a few
generals who may be answering to some
higher authority out there but basically
any real stay any real possibility of a
unified offensive front from the United
States is a pipe dream it's gone it's
out of the picture right that's not a
possibility and so with that then it
turns into how many more other places
are they gonna start attacking right you
know there's attacks coming in from
Israel and other countries like who's
next what are we gonna do here and so
that's when they start asking kind of
the hard-hitting questions you know like
like how soon will they be at these
various cities what steps are we going
to take and so that's when the United
Nations is this kind of group here
basically sits down and says then we're
gonna do the only thing that we can do
this is utilitarianism the needs of the
many outweigh the needs of the few New
York we can assume that there's maybe a
50% survival rate among the people who
were there which means are still a few
million people occupying that city and
the United States you got maybe 290
probably around the time the story was
written assuming that there's not too
different so we can say by 275 million
people in the
United States there's billions of people
in the world gentlemen we're gonna do
the only thing that we can do here we
are going to nuke the entire city of New
York with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob pork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]